hey 42 here in a world builds upon trade
and commerce we assign value to items
locations and experiences in our lives
via their monetary cost which can be
effected in any number of ways to play
and demand for instance not to mention
rarity in other words the more valuable
we consider something to be the more we
are willing to pay for it and if you
have a lot of money to throw around
there are plenty of ways to flex your
wealth for yourself or for others if you
just know where to look to get you
started let's check out nine of the most
expensive things in the world we start
with the world's most expensive car
the 1962 Ferrari 250 GTO a classic car
enthusiasts dream come true
a gorgeous two-seater with plenty of
horsepower thanks to the 3 litre v12
engine rumbling beneath the hood it's
going to get you where you're going with
all the style and poise that's made
Ferrari famous before you can say
speeding ticket though it makes a bold
statement on the motorways its origins
lie in secrecy behind closed doors in
1961 after learning of the shiny new GT
that Jaguar had introduced to the racing
world Enzo Ferrari tasked one of his top
engineers with Ferraris response the
engineer Giotto bizarre weenie assembled
a small group of dependable men unset'
to work drumming up schematics for what
will become the 250 GTO after several
months of grueling work it was to be
faster lighter and more powerful than
the flagship Ferraris of the time and
much to Enzo's relief early tests showed
that Bissell Rania's design passed with
flying colors one model custom-made for
the famous British racecar driver
Stirling Moss recently sold for just
over 38 million US dollars at auction
setting a world record for the most
money to ever exchange hands in the sale
of a car though this particular car has
seen a great deal of wear inter haven't
been raced crashed and repaired many
times over its lifetime
this firecracker of a Ferrari saw
bidding begin at no less than eleven
million dollars before reaching the
historic record of 38 million dollars
for true car enthusiasts every car has a
story age and dents included holding the
keys to your own little portion of car
rating history is certainly a priceless
experience when it comes to jewelry
diamonds are the gem of choice to set in
rings necklaces and earrings of the
diamond family the type best-known by
the public is the relatively common
white diamond but diamonds actually come
in a wide variety of colors and not all
the colors are synthetically produced
among the crowd favorite gemstones
authentic pink diamonds are the rarest
and most valuable of them all so it
should come as no surprise that the
monsterous 59.6 carat pink star diamond
is currently the most expensive gemstone
in the world the pink star went to
auction in 2014 prompting diamond cutter
Isaac Wolfe to place a bid for a
remarkable eighty-three point two
million dollars shutting out all rival
bidders in the process he even renamed
the gem to the pink dream while the bid
was in progress seemingly ready to make
his own dreams come true but in the end
it seems he may have only been
interested in the prestige that comes
with making such an offer as he never
actually finalized payment for the gem
of course dealing in such vast amounts
of money is often a grand dance between
would-be buyers and the investors
backing them perhaps there was a bit of
a mix-up at the bank you've got to be
careful counting so many zeros after
Isaac defaulted on payment for the gem
it was placed back in the care of Sava
Bea's the world leader in luxury items
and auctions for now it remains in their
possession revalued at a more affordable
seventy two million dollars though that
is hardly the upper limit due to the
rarity and unusual size of the gem at
that price it's simply a steal
to purchase it before it goes back to
auction our homes serve many purposes
they are our castles our sanctums our
refuges from the hustle and bustle of
the outside world so it's no small
wonder that our homes say a lot about
who we are and what we value the most
for billionaire Mukesh Ambani the
wealthiest man in India his home
represents his vast wealth and it's
appropriately awesome in execution he
named the towering spire Antilia after a
mysterious and possibly mythological
island in the Atlantic Ocean
clearly Mukesh is not one for subtlety
the one billion dollar home looks every
bit as legendary as its namesake and
bares the unique honor of being the most
expensive home in the world Antilia has
a total of 27 stories six of which are
comprised of a subterranean parking
garage one floor which is devoted
entirely to health and wellness four
floors of lavish open-air gardens one
for a cinema of course six residential
floors for guests and family and free
floor set aside strictly for maintenance
purposes to keep everything running
smoothly and of course no billionaire
Chateau would be complete without its
very own dedicated staff nearly 600
people see to every nook and cranny of
this monolithic dream home the expenses
might seem staggering just imagine his
monthly utility bills but for a man with
a net worth of over 27 billion dollars
the effect such a home has on his wallet
is probably no more than a drop in the
ocean the whole building is reinforced
against a variety of disasters both
natural and potentially malicious in
nature Antilia is built to stand tall in
the face of magnitude 8 earthquake and
can even withstand military-grade
explosions but all things considered
mister Ambani's magnificent domicile
only cost an estimated 77 million
dollars to build
yep that's a 923 million dollar return
on investment though he shows no
indication that he
we'll be interested in selling for now
it looks like if you want your very own
Tower of extravagance you're going to
have to rustle up 77 million and build
your own Hollywood is no stranger to
multimillion-dollar productions but
every few years a special sort of film
comes along that ups the ante the
Pirates of the Caribbean films were
smash hits at the box office
so for the ongoing Adventures of the
swashbuckling Captain Jack Sparrow it's
hardly a surprise that Disney spared no
expense the fourth film in the series
Pirates of the Caribbean on Stranger
Tides managed to rack up an impressive
410 point six million dollars in costs
before adjustment for tax credits and
other assistance making it the most
expensive production in cinema to date
cameras rolled in exotic locales across
the globe to set all manner of piratical
excitement to celluloid film even
filming some scenes in jolly old England
in addition to being a fantastic country
all round it's likely that the producers
were interested in the British tax
credit offer two films costing more than
34 point 1 million dollars just one of
the many ways Disney executives sought
to soften the blow of the bottom line
disney banked a lot on the captain and
his crew unluckily for the house of
mouse their gamble paid off
worldwide takes for the film sailed
straight past a 1 billion dollar mark as
the captain and his crew made their way
to greener waters I'm no mathematician
but that sounds like a resounding
financial success to me with a fifth
film on the horizon will the pirates be
able to plunder the box office again I
suppose we'll just have to wait and see
occasionally we put our collective funds
towards the betterment of all mankind
the International Space Station sitting
in low-earth orbit 330 kilometers above
the surface of our planet represents the
combined resources and ingenuity of five
major space agencies across the world
the total cost of 100 billion dollars
has been shared among all nations
contributing to the project since its
inception making it the most expensive
man-made object we have today the
purpose of the ISS is to provide a semi
permanent orbital lab where humankind
can perform scientific experiments that
take advantage of the unique
interactions of gravity temperature and
pressure in space performing many tests
which would be simply impossible
otherwise astronauts also have the
privilege of testing cutting-edge
industrial materials and innovative
communications technology as well as
gathering data for medical research on
the side despite what you might think it
isn't all floaty fun and games in space
there's actually an awful lot of work
that gets done the ISS was granted a
recent extension of its life cycle now
projected to last through to 2024 it
certainly pays to look to the future
when dealing with space long term the
Russian Rose cosmos and us-based NASA
are drawing got plans for a new station
to be constructed after the ISS reaches
its end of life what comes after that is
anyone's guess but if Star Trek has
taught us anything it's that one of
humanity's noblest aspirations is to
boldly go where no one has gone before
and then make friends of aliens
regardless of the cost we assigned to
them books are one of the most valuable
commodities we have they provide the
opportunity to reach across time and
space sharing information concepts and
ideas with always of our time and
generations yet to come of all of the
influential figures throughout history
who's fought might be worth reading the
great Leonardo da Vinci would
doubtlessly rank quite highly one of his
compiled manuscript the Codex Leicester
sold at auction in 1994 to Microsoft
co-founder Bill Gates for over 30
million dollars the greatest amount of
money to ever change hands in the sale
of a book also known as the Codex hammer
after the previous owner of the
manuscript the Codex Leicester was
written by da Vinci over a period of
time between 1506 and 1530 it is unusual
work for the renowned inventor and
artist due to the compilations laser
focus on a single topic the study of
water
among the pages are sheets of
calculations and musings on everything
from water currents and whirlpools to
practical uses for water in structures
like canals locks and dams admittedly a
bit of a fanboy
mr. gates finds value in the work of da
Vinci because quoting quote he
personally worked out science on his own
also noting that every one of da Vinci's
notebooks are amazing documents they're
kind of his rough draft note of tags
that he eventually wanted to put
together so save your doodles and scraps
because someday a billionaire might be
willing to pay top dollar for them when
you consider that water is essential for
human life it seems rather difficult to
put a price on it
of course water is a common page utility
in many countries and people can also
enjoy it by the bottle for convenience
but the existential question always
remains the California based Beverly
Hills drink company seems to have made
peace with the issue going so far as to
offer the self-proclaimed most expensive
bottle of water in the world for
unaffordable $100,000 only nine bottles
of their luxury collection Diamond
Edition bottles were made rendering the
experience as exclusive as you might
expect the bottles were designed by
jeweler Mario Padilla to be the perfect
complement to the unique first quenching
experience each one sealed with a cap
made of white gold set with over 600
white diamonds and 250 black diamonds
for a total of 14 carats worth of gems a
special case filled with four engraved
Baccarat crystal tumblers completes the
package and it's all accompanied by a
personal private water tasting
presentation anywhere in the world by
water Somalia yes that's actually a job
martin rees whatever you have a passion
for there's a way to make a living doing
it even if that passion is water tasting
after a taste test of the $100,000 water
by American musicians 2 Chainz and Diplo
they reported that the water tastes
fruit despite their self-proclaimed a
quiet expensive taste after the tasting
2 Chainz sagely noted that if you put a
diamond on something they're going to
run up the tab on you and that neither
one of us believe that we should pay
$100,000 for a bottle of water but if
you choose to investigate the Diamond
Collection for yourself be sure to take
advantage of the one-year supply of free
water refills make the most of that
diamond encrusted bottle very few
artists are lucky enough to see their
work appreciated on a grand scale a 19th
century painter Paul Gauguin is no
exception it would certainly come as a
surprise to him that one of his works
would eventually become the priciest
painting in the world
fetching 300 million dollars in a
secretive auction over a century after
he first set color to cumbers the
painting entitled when will you marry
depicts a snapshot of the heat in life
in the late 1800 and was the result of
Gauguin sabbatical on the Polynesian
island in search of quote-unquote anni
Zdenek paradise to inspire pure
primitive art it was sold by a Swiss
private collector in February of 2015 to
an enigmatic buyer who chose not to
reveal their identity publicly during
the sale
Rudolph's stay telling a former
executive with the luxury auction house
Sotheby's confirmed the sale which was
made via his family trust with the go
gambiing only one of at least twenty
other magnificent works of art in his
possession from the impressionist and
post-impressionist Eva he seemingly
suffered from a rare case of having so
much priceless artwork that he truly
didn't know what to do with it all
before the auctions d Challen had been
loaning when will you marry to the
Kunstmuseum in switzerland along with
other pieces of art from his private
collection when asked what prompted the
sale he replied quite simply that we got
a good offer
unfortunately for the swiss museum
curators they will have to hope for
another philanthropy donation to fill
the newly empties exhibit smartphones
have become an integral part of our
cultural identity
equal parts tools and stutter symbols
the brands we choose and the accessories
we decorate them with can reveal quite a
lot about a person one Chinese
businessman decided that the options
available at his local electronics store
simply didn't cut it for him so what did
he do
why customized an iPhone 5 over 26 carat
black diamonds and a body made of gold
of course and all told it cost a
staggering fifteen point three million
dollars the most expensive smartphone
out there today the phone was the result
of a request sent to the UK based
craftsmen Stewart Hughes who specializes
in high-end luxury smartphones
it took nine weeks to assemble and
includes 135 grams of 24 karat gold and
653 diamonds in the design the giant
black diamond at the heart of it all
seated where the home button normally
sits was a family heirloom passed down
through the anonymous business man's
family for generations
rather than build a display case for it
to set up on the mantel he chose to use
it as his daily phone giving him the
opportunity to show it off at every
corporate meeting and business lunch
before the Black Diamond iPhone crossed
his desk Hughes had worked up an iPhone
4s made of gold that was valued at six
million British pounds it held the world
record for the most expensive smartphone
only briefly before this one came along
and smashed that record to pieces
whether the Black Diamond iPhone will be
a decision that the businessman comes to
regret who can say but if there's one
thing for certain it's a good smartphone
is indeed worth its weight in gold
thanks for the view subscribe for more
thoughty2
you